هذا هو أليك لسنوات يقول إنه عمل
كمدفع مستأجر في سوريا
لمجموعة مرتزقة روسية غامضة تسمى فوغنر
والتي أصبحت أداة قيّمة
للكرملين فوغنر هي أداة بوتين
لحل المشكلات بالقوة عندما يتعين اتخاذ إجراء
على الفور وبشكل عاجل
بأكبر قدر ممكن من الخفاء
، لا أستطيع أن أقول إنه جيش بالمعنى الصحيح
لهذه الكلمة ، إنه مجرد وحدة قتالية
ستفعل أي شيء يقول بوتين
إنها المرة الأولى التي
يوافق فيها على التحدث أمام الكاميرا وطلب
منا أوليغ إخفاء صورته.
المتعاقدون العسكريون الخاصون للهوية غير قانونيين في
روسيا رسميًا لا وجود لـ
vogner لكن cNN اكتشفت أن المجموعة
لديها الآن مئات المقاتلين الذين يعملون
في ثلاث قارات مختلفة وهذا
هو الرجل الذي يعتقد أنه وراء هذا
التوسع الذي أطلق عليه اسم طاه بوتين بسبب
عقود تقديم الطعام المربحة  مع
الكرملين
يفغيني الجميل ، تم معاقبة جورجون أيضًا من
قبل الولايات المتحدة لتمويله
وكالة أبحاث الإنترنت المتهمة
بالتدخل في  انتخابات عام 2016 ، أنا
مرتزق وكان تسعون بالمائة من
المشاركين في الشركة
مثلي وكانوا مدفوعين بالمال ، ما هو
نوع التدريب الذي تم فيه ، كما
تعلمون ، لم أتلق أي
تدريب على هذا النحو وليس في أي تدريب.  الطريقة التي أمضيت بها
ستة أيام في المعسكر التدريبي في الحليب ،
كما تعلم ، ذهبت إلى ميدان الرماية مرتين
وأطلقت النار على مدفع رشاش مرة واحدة حيث
سافرت CNN إلى
قرية Mulkey الروسية النائية لمحاولة الوصول إلى
معسكر تدريب vogner ووجدت ذلك
تتمتع المجموعة بعلاقة وثيقة بشكل مدهش
مع الجيش الروسي
، والطريقة الوحيدة
للوصول إلى ثكنات فوغنر هي
المرور عبر نقطة التفتيش التي
يديرها الجيش الروسي لأنها في
الواقع تنتمي إلى وحدة القوات الخاصة الروسية
ليست بعيدة عن موتشي ، فلا يوجد  النصب
التذكاري للزوار الذين سقطوا من مقاتلي فوجنر
غير مرحب بهم ،
لذلك نقترب بكاميرا خفية ، فهي
تبدو وكأنها نصب تذكاري أكثر من كونها
حصنًا يأتي الحارس إلينا قريبًا
وهي الكنيسة فقط لـ vogner I a  sked
لا أعرف لمن يقول
للأشخاص الذين كانوا في سوريا أضغط عليه.
اترك نعم ، سيذهب نيكول ،
دعنا نذهب ، لم يسمحوا لنا بالدخول ، وهذا
ليس مفاجئًا لأنه في هذا
المركب هو الدليل الوحيد الملموس
على أن فوغنر حقيقي وليس مفاجئًا
ربما أن النصب تم تمويله من قبل
شركة مملوكة للترويج.
منذ سنوات في شبه جزيرة القرم ، ساعد
مقاتلون غامضون مجهولون يطلق عليهم اسم
رجال خضر صغار موسكو على إراحة
المقاطعة من أوكرانيا حتى مع
جهل الكرملين المزعوم ، فقد كان هذا
نجاحًا وازداد استخدام موسكو لقوات المرتزقة
منذ ذلك الحين ، ويقول المحللون إن أياً
من هذا لا يمكن أن يحدث بدون موافقة بوتين.
أعتقد أن جزءًا من
مهمة vogner هو مساعدة روسيا على
استعادة دورها لتصبح
قوة عظمى عالمية كبرى مرة أخرى نعم 100٪ هذه هي
الأولوية القصوى لـ vogner ولذا فهي
تحاول أن تكون منافسًا لأمريكا روسي
يحاول a قمع الولايات المتحدة.  بكل
طريقة ممكنة ، باستخدام الوسائل القانونية وغير القانونية ،
إنها تحاول
تحطيمها ، والاستفادة منها بطريقة أو بأخرى ، ما سيحدث نتيجة لذلك لا أعتقد أن شيئًا جيدًا ، لكن بالنسبة للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين ، لا يزال فوجنر مقامرة جديرة بالاهتمام ، وهي
قوة قتالية مستهلكة بلا
المساءلة كلاريسا وارد سي إن إن مولكي
نو روسيا
[موسيقى]